Joe Biden's re-election run could be
stumbling into more embarrassment this
campaign season and there's no sandbags
around that he can blame this time team
Biden is worried that the president
could lose the first two contests of the
primary season to a challenger like RFK
Jr it's thanks to the Democrat strategy
of ignoring all states that put their
primaries ahead of South Carolina a win
could give RFK Jr major momentum as
Democrats search for an alternative
candidate that isn't scared to go on the
campaign Trail or that can actually
function
we've mobilize the world's leading
emitters to help poor countries deal
with impacts of climate change they
called it the G7 the bill back Biden
Bill back better and we realized that
got confusing so now we don't call it
that we have plans to build a railroad
from the Pacific all the way across the
Indian Ocean we have plans to build in
in Angola one of the largest solar
plants in the world I can go on but I'm
on I'm going off script I'm going to get
in trouble
that is off the script and to make
matters worse a focus group of North
Carolina swing voters says that they're
concerned by Biden's age but whatever
you do don't bother Nancy Pelosi about
it
do you think that President Biden's age
has finally caught up to him at all
absolutely not I think the president is
great I look I'm proud to be supporting
him and I don't even know why you asked
that question do you think he has the
stamina to finish a second term if he
were yes I do and please don't bother me
with such frivolity okay
like ice cream all right Biden is
hosting uh movie night speaking of
frivolity at the White House
for a flick about the dude who claims to
have invented flaming hot Cheetos you
know Dana flaming hot Cheetos that's
exactly how Hunter describes what it's
like to pee to his doctor
yes it heard yes John that was a good
one I thought it was the name of your
band in high school oh then no that was
phallic death but
there's a lot of jockeying going around
for Biden's replacement yeah you know to
get that feeling and there was the
Vanity Fair piece on uh what's her name
the Gretchen Whitmer thank you yeah yeah
yeah written by a not just written by a
reporter but written by a very well
respected credible Democratic strategist
who's had a lot of time in the white
house or worked for Obama so that was
interesting now she might uh truly
believe it or she might be trying to
stir the pot or she just got the
assignment and said let me just tell you
what and call it like I see it I do
think that Nancy Pelosi's answer about
frivaldi it's a good way to shut
somebody down I could imagine somebody
like Trump giving an answer like that
like don't ever bother with me like that
again and Hillary to our credit never
stops but Joe Biden just said in that
speech we are going to build a train
from the Pacific across the Indian Ocean
and she thinks that's frivolous as a
question the answers are right there for
themselves I do think the Democrats are
going to write off Iowa and New
Hampshire as fakes they're going to say
it doesn't matter because they have the
DNC this is usually what happens when
you have an incumbent president they
don't debate they don't they just go
straight to the convention without
having to stop and pay the 200 there you
go Emily great to see you you know in
Joe's defense the less you know of
another candidate the better right it's
like most popular candidates generally
is the generic one but the problem is
RFK Jr is quite charming and persuasive
what say you well agree with what Dana
just said about the fact that that
response sort of shoots it down but
that's what this white house is so good
at and what and what the media is so
good at which is essentially being
dismissive right they love to diminish
they love to dismiss the questions and
therefore by inference you're dismissing
the person asking the question why
shouldn't we ask about his age and his
competence given the clear
other planet that he's living on so the
Aegis is frivolous for asking about it
and RFK Jr he's called Fringe right
Newsweek published an op-ed that said
we're not for his illustrious name he'd
be just another crackpot in the growing
list of bottom feeding right-wing Fringe
politicians Esquire published one that
said oh anyone else that goes against an
incumbent president with 20 that's
cannon fodder but they're dismissing the
question which is people saying we are
not satisfied in the Democrat Party with
who is in office please God anyone but
Biden or Kamala so no wonder they're
polling high and percentages are high
when you talk about the frivolity of
Cheetos you know yeah we call it
frivolity but the White House is calling
it campaigning there is a reason why 30
37 percent of Latino voters feel that
Biden and the Democrats don't care about
the Latino Community it's because they
are checking boxes we're going to show
this movie we're going to compare them
to breakfast tacos we're going to pay
Seven figures to air bilingual
commercials and call call that a
campaign we're going to play despacito
and think that that is a connective
tissue with actual Latino Americans and
there's a reason why the same amount 37
percent believe that the GOP carries a
great deal and it's because we care
about all Americans right we care about
the economy and border security and Law
and Order and education and freedom to
worship no maybe a country that doesn't
identify them as a prop as a prop to get
their political virtue signal on so I
think this is sometimes laughable at a
minimum but at maximum it's horribly
patently offensive
Jesse people often call you a Flamin Hot
Cheeto
um RFK feels like they're going to treat
him like Bernie Sanders right he's going
to be what the people like but not what
the elites want so they're going to try
to push them out even though again you
know is clearly a better Persuader who's
up on the issues unlike Joe who's a
daughtering fool I
unceremoniously disinvited RFK Jr from
prime time now RFK Junior wants to come
on
you know when you ignore them then all
of a sudden they're into you so tonight
no one ever
so tonight we will put it up to a poll
whether or not I should reconsider my
disinvitation and have him on Joe
Biden's a lazy bully Joe oh are you are
you upset that you might lose Iowa Joe
are you upset you might be embarrassed
in New Hampshire oh are there too many
white people in Iowa New Hampshire well
I didn't Barack Obama win Iowa Brock's
black and then he won New Hampshire the
second time so Joe has to rig his own
primary to save face
that's like yeah how many times did you
run for president this is the fourth
time the minute he gets power he rigs
this is like
being a triathlete never winning you
finally win and you guys are like you
know what we're going to reverse the
order we're gonna run first then swim
and finish with cycling you can't do
that everybody knows it's Bush league so
think about the precedent this sets
though
every president once they win they're
just gonna pick a state which whatever
they did best in and then go there first
every president from now on is gonna
raid their opponent's house and have
them arrested every president from now
on is not going to do the Fox News Super
Bowl interview these are terrible
precedents that cannot stand and he's
gotten special treatment up to this
point by the FBI the Democrats and the
Press but now I'm glad New Hampshire and
Iowa they're not going to get bullied
and they're going to put it on and RFK
is going to probably win both because no
one wants to write in Joe Biden and it's
going to catch some momentum and it's
going to be humiliating and he deserves
the humiliation there you go well put
you know Jessica uh a really important
question how much money do you think
it's going to cost me from Uber
since my dog had explosive diarrhea in
the back seat
I'm going to try to connect that yes it
was a pet Uber though yeah they are I
think more prepared for that if you
think that that's eating my talk time
though
um
and would also like to highlight as we
know that people to judge won Iowa last
time which was a complete debacle to the
point that the head of the democratic
party in Iowa had to step down from that
and basically agreed with the fact that
they shouldn't go first there and then
he lost New Hampshire where Bernie
Sanders wanted people to judge came in
second so the humiliation has already
happened and then he already won that's
the thing everyone lays out all these
things oh Joe's you know polling so
badly Carmel is this or whatever and
they keep winning so take that into
account with this on the RFK front I
have still yet to meet a real live
Democrat that likes RFK we enjoyed the
piece on Cheryl Hines that came out on
the New York Times on Friday I thought
that that was interesting and to hear
about you know how she's kind of been
thrust into this political world that
she was never part of and how she's
using her improv skills from having been
part of the Groundlings to kind of get
through this but she has tremendous
problems with her own husband's policies
mostly his anti-backs throw the spouse
under the bus she threw him first I'm
just telling the people in case you
haven't read the article which I'd
recommend everyone does I did read it so
okay anyway
um no he didn't I sent it to him and I
think he thumbs up I read that and an
interesting article about Willie Brown
RFK is still the guy who was originally
boosted by Steve Bannon Steve Bannon
does not want what's best for the
Democratic party he also doesn't want
what's best for the for the country I
know there are people on the right who
might say that that's wrong but I'm
telling you that that's certainly how we
feel here and when you say that his
positions are really interesting last
week he came on with Neil Cavuto and he
said we killed 350 000 Ukrainian kids
for a sham something like that they are
going and fighting believing that
they're fighting for their Nation thank
God Neil fact checked him and said no
it's actually the Russians that are
killing that are killing the ukrainians
his position on that war is more than
Fringe it's more than cuckoo it is so
out of step with what's going on the sun
is fighting in that war against the
Russians does that does that make what
he said accurate No it may it makes it
makes his it makes him even more insane
in fact I think you just don't like it
because he's anti-war no you are I would
love it or person that's why you're
wearing red
what yeah I've just say yeah
[Laughter]
RFK is not I guess I take issue with you
saying you haven't met a Democrat who
supports RFK I have where are you
hanging out in Republican bars yes I
know I find them everywhere actually
Jessica then that sort of raises the
question more if if that's true like
let's take that it's true that it's even
more insane that such a high percentage
of Democrats are actually voting it
shows Biden's lack of first of all in
the polar has favorability in the
quinnipeg Quinnipiac poll it's higher
than bidens he is 43 who say they don't
know they don't have an opinion of the
guy he has not been mainstreamed
whatsoever and I think everyone should
be heard but to take it as gospel that
this guy is really permeating the
Democratic base is a complete fallacy
let's just let it be noted that you did
not answer the first question is sick
and it will be 100 to 200 500 I'm gonna
say 500 all right well thank you Jessica
for offering to pay all right hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else